ihr habt euch zahlreich gewünscht dass
ich mal auf - reagiere
deswegen klicke ich hier direkt auf play
jetzt schon keinen bock mehr
die videos kenne ich da fällt das runter
und auf der anderen seite wieder hoch
oder tief im fels einfach runter da in
bayern wir neuerdings und gymnastikball
auf dem ich immer drauf sitze hier so
einer
und da rutscht man ab und zu mal drauf
weg diese ganze geschichte hillary
clinton gegen donald trump das ist ja
auch ein einziges mimen gewesen die
ganzen speeches
stellt er die woher weißt du auch die
letzte was sie danach die hände denkt er
würde ich mir die trocken
wie kannst du so ein ding denn direkt
über die mülltonne setzen okay hier
haben wir einen nicht so muskulösen
menschen deren beine trainiert hat jetzt
kommen die man an der schon ein bisschen
stabiler ist ok er ist jetzt abgehakt
und will jetzt auch so viel machen
[Musik]
die hunde sind 240 steuerte lebewesen
walter ich hatte gerade her
steht auf einmal so einen frosch in
tusche mein gott ich dachte das war ein
echter tiger
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
oh mein gott habe ich mich erschrocken
alter dass er ein ganz schön krass alter
schwede
warum gehe ich auch jedes mal näher an
den bildschirmrand
[Musik]
ich lach wirklich nur weil so eine dumme
scheiße
warum macht man sowas
[Gelächter]
das habe ich mir die ganze zeit gedacht
weil das hier lief immer als werbung für
tik tok und die controller ist einfach
nicht an
9.08 uhr heilige scheiße den folgen
locker zwei oder tauben
[Musik]
kann ich auch haben rückenwind
was
das habe ich mich aber wirklich schon
mal gefragt wie funktionieren diese
einöde robot sachen
man muss da einfach draufklicken es
steht einfach scheiße ich sehe gerade
das video gibt sogar wirklich
[Musik]
an der stelle würde ich meinem reaction
jetzt heute allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren ganz ganz viele
leute von euch haben sich gewünscht dass
ich mal auch normale - reagiere nicht
irgendwie auf lukas noll stunde oder auf
- mit meiner fresse drauf sondern
wirklich auf normalem center video
gefallen hat das gerne mal einen daumen
hoch da schreibt mir geld in die
kommentare ob ich das ganze noch mal
machen soll und sonst
[Musik]
die